hey guys and welcome to another episode
of my 1hour flipping challenge today
continuing on with the trend of changing
up the amount of money I start with as
the category we are going to be going
all the way down to 1 mil as a starting
cash amount now I wouldn't really
recommend going much lower than this
because the return just gets worse and
worse that being said I got a huge
amount of money back for considering how
much money I started with I did
exceptionally well I must say um but if
you want to know for sure definitely go
ahead and watch till the end all right
hope you guys enjoy and let's get
started all right guys so today we're
going to be starting with 1 mil in our
inventory now there are a couple
different ways we could take this with
today uh we could go for some high
volume flips uh but I don't really
believe that high volume flips are going
to be worth it when you only have 1 mil
cuz sure you might get 3 4% back um
you're going to have to actively be
monitoring the prices and what I might
get 30k back after 10 or 20 minutes of
actively flipping might not be worth it
so what we're going to do instead is go
for some um
medium velocity items so stuff like uh
well the serom and deh's good unly
blessing around the 100 200k Mark and we
might get a 12K or even let's see here h
of Darkness has a 25k return so yeah I
mean like some of these items might be
good and we won't have to be actively
flipping so much for those who only have
one mil I would personally recommend
just leaving offers in for rare items
and coming back and flipping them as
opposed to flipping high volume items
but that's my personal advice anyway
let's get started 60 minutes on the
clock let's go so to start off I think
we're going to look at this zamak plate
body of course we want to look into the
item B bit more and for those who don't
know I'm using G tracker uh to look up
all the prices right now as well as um
all the margins and stuff like that so
first up we have the zamak play body
first we're going to look at how many
are traded uh per hour so about 10 to 20
uh which is fine and we'll go put a
lowball offer in
about um maybe
61k so zamra plate body uh we're only
going to go for one at a time because we
want to make sure we have the right
price and since we don't have a lot of
money to work with we're just going to
go for 61k just go for one of those all
right looks like we actually instantly
bought that interesting um well we'll go
ahead and try to sell that back clearly
that was not the right price we'll go
for 65k
all right that is interesting uh we just
looking up another item that already
sold for 65k uh so in that case I think
we're going to lower that down a bit
we'll try buying it for uh
57k and we'll go for two or three of
those uh next up I want to have a look
at the Unholy
blessing uh but 184k trades about how
many per hour
roughly uh kind of similar about 9 to 10
so we could probably look to get maybe 9
or 10 roughly all right so I think we're
going to undercut on the Unholy blessing
a bit uh we're going to go for 176k and
just hope we get one of those uh
strangely enough we already got another
three of the plate bodies this might
actually be a really good item plop them
in for
65k I didn't actually expect flips like
this to go off so quickly so 195 and we
bought them all for 171 sounds about 24K
and considering we only started with one
mil it's extremely good we're going to
definitely go back and buy some more of
those go for another three for now and I
think we're going lower down a little
more 54k cuz I don't even know what the
margin is maybe we should just buy and
sell one of these
honestly and we'll go for 54k for now
next up I think we're going to look at
the gothic Dragon hide and I'm very
impressed by the margins on items like
this cuz they do trade a lot enough to
actually do this in my challenge Gothic
Dragonite is what we're looking at and
we're going to go for 75k and we'll go
for three of
those and the blessing um we'll toss in
for 196k about a 20K margin that is
decent
196 and uh last up for the rest of our
money is actually a barrows item I did
not expect to be able to do A barrows
item but we're going to do it about 196
we're going to try buying it for uh yeah
about
196 and we're going to do the ver Rock
brassard uh for 196 and I did w that's
pretty good and do one of those all
right that's it guys we're just going to
wait for these offers to come through
and we'll be back in a minute all right
we're back and we have sold the Unholy
blessing so for
196k that is going to be a 20K profit I
think we're going to go ahead and buy
another one of those first here and what
are we buying them for again
176 H looks good we've also sold off a
zamra play body and bought a new one as
well so the items are slowly coming
through okay we've sold off all these
Zam play bodies or bought them all sorry
for 57k that's another two or three
sorry and uh we're going to sell them
for 65 that's a great margin we've
almost sold them off already too and
we'll pop them in over here we got a lot
of offer slots available which is kind
of nice and uh that yeah 7K on each um
so far three that's 21k we're definitely
going to go buy some more of those all
right this actually looks like a really
promising item the torn prayer scroll uh
looks like it has about a 10 game margin
on it and this item trades a lot I mean
it's a brand new item well new is came
out with raids anyway and U oh we've got
the Unholy blessings coming through as
well all right 176 and 176 we're going
to pop those in for 196 down
here
196k and if we pull out the gothic
Dragonite that's not coming through and
well neither is this honestly but for
now we'll just go ahead and buy uh one
One to begin with see if we can buy it
for about
50k oh wait we didn't whoops dor prayer
scroll and we'll try buying it for
5500 and we can only afford one
unfortunately but we'll see how that
works for now okay both of the in holy
blessings have sold for another 20K
margin wow that's actually extremely
good uh 196 on that one and the am blade
bodies are starting to come through
again a 7K margin on each of those 8K
sorry I'm an idiot okay so we have an
holy blessing coming in for 176 going to
sell that out for 196 definitely our
Powerhouse item so far another 20K in
each one of those and we did just sell a
torn press scroll as well for 59500
which is extremely good and we buy
another one of those quickly Tor press
scroll uh was it
5500 and we'll try definitely to max out
that only two more one more after this
one we could flip and on top of that we
also do have a verox brassard coming in
for
201k and I we try flipping that for
209k it's actually pretty fun doing this
little tiny margin flips well not really
tiny honestly just uh very lowrisk cheap
items I'm enjoying it and we sold off
the torn press Scrolls
nice okay so we have the verox brussard
coming in for another one for 201k going
to pop this other one in for 209
hopefully it'll sell soon cuz that's a
lot of money actually invested in there
and we did find a another good item I
want to try but we don't have any well I
guess we got some money here we can pull
out another press roll and uh well we'll
keep the slot available and the item I
want to try is the mud battle staff I'll
get over here for you looks to trade
pretty frequently especially during the
day uh we can maybe flip uh five or six
of these looks like it has about a 7K
margin which isn't as good as the other
ones but uh the item is pretty cheap
it's only 65 K we're going to try buying
it for
65 100 and we'll go for well I guess
just two of those we can afford right
now
unfortunately okay we have a whole load
of stuff coming in right now we have uh
a brck brassard we sold now we did lower
down for quite a bit so we only got a 5k
margin on that uh we have a bunch of
torn prayer Scrolls coming through and
uh Zam plate bodies have sold
unfortunately we weren't able to really
buy any more of those the Unholy
blessing we also sold for 196
get extremely good margin on that
definitely going to continue buying
these the entire time pretty well and
we'll take out these torn prayer Scrolls
and pop it in for
59500 that's another 20K we're getting
on these and the mud battle stabs came
through as well one so far okay so we
have a lot of actual offer slots getting
freed up right now we're going to put in
the brine saber cuz it looks like it's
about a 10K margin uh but we have the
Tor press Scrolls coming through and
they're already sold for 59500 this
would have been an awesome item to
continue doing but unfortunately the
limit is very low only but five uh we
have a mud battle staff coming through
and try selling that for uh 71k I think
it was and remember 71k and uh what
we're going to move on to now is the Bri
saber like I said looks like 181 into
165 looks pretty good to me so we'll put
in the Brian saber for 16
5 500 and we'll do two all right we're
back and we have finally sold off some
of these items the ver brassard 206 nice
to get that money back mud battle staff
sold for 71k and our final Tor press
scroll sold for another 10K profit which
is awesome next up really excited to try
the Sears ring all these items I
actually didn't think I'd be able to do
but I look at this like a that's a huge
margin we'll try buying it for
258 and we can only buy one at a time
but it's still a pretty quick moving
item so this should be good try for
258 and mud batt slabs aren't coming
through I think we actually pull this
out and try to buy another one since we
haven't bought an actual plate body in
quite a while we'll go for another one
all right we have one seies ring coming
in so far
258k and we're going to try selling it
for H what was it
again it's pretty high but
268 that is oh it's only 10K actually
kind of looked a lot more on the graph
but uh I mean that's still 10K pretty
good we'll try selling it for
268 all right so right away we have one
selling for 268 and another one buying
for 258 pop that in quickly to sell I
think we could flip all eight of these
very quickly let's see if we can get
keep this 10K margin to ourselves uh
it's going to be close because uh well
people jump on these items very quickly
Sears
ring 258k do we have enough money need
to invest in another one if we pull out
the mud battle stab and we'll pull out
the Unholy blessing that's not coming
through very quick and we'll go try to
buy another seies ring quickly to see if
we can actually flip all five of these
or six eight H who knows okay we have
both the seies ring coming through
already like I said this is a very quick
item and we're going to have to sell
those off for
268 uh very happy with that margin
though and
268 hopefully these are both actually
the right price oh there we go our other
one came through right away looks like
we're good
okay we have another Sears ring coming
in for 268 the rest are hopefully
selling off pretty soon here and we
found yet again another amazing item for
the price point and that is the granite
Maul um 18K it's saying but um the price
is fluctuating so much it says down to
239 right now uh so we can definitely a
[__] it let's go and try to buy it for
240 [__] you write
this TZ something at home whatever this
one is and we're going to try buying it
for 239 or 240 the price is in flux
quite a bit right now uh but hopefully
since this item trades so much we can
buy it quickly and sell it off I kid you
not like 5 seconds later we already have
one coming through for 240 G tracker
saying 273 is that what we going to go
for we'll go for 273 that is in a crazy
margin for the price I would be totally
happy with that come on let's go 273 and
we have another Sears ring coming in and
we have any more money so we can buy
another Granite item doesn't look like
it h we'll sell up for 268 as well and
that's pretty much all our money guys
okay we have another Granite Mall you
guys are going to kill me if this isn't
the granite mall I got to look this up
right
now
SAR k um this must be the Grand
Mall obsidian Mall
[__] all right te me the shreds whatever
but anyway it has a good margin and
another one came in for 240 try selling
this one for 272 hopefully we can
actually get these sold because that is
a 20 32k margin that's insane another
Sears ring coming in and we have enough
money to buy another Granite Mall which
we definitely will do uh
240 actually we buy oh we'll buy two
let's just double down this item all
right so we have another obsidian Mall
coming in for 272 that's a good profit
on that that is like I said 32k another
one coming through we'll drop them both
down to 272k who gives a the [__] that's
just 1K in profit we don't really care
about that too much and the Sears ring
is coming through at 268 so we're kind
of down to just the one item now and uh
well maybe we should Branch out a little
bit cuz these are coming through but not
as quickly as I'd hoped all right we
have some more obsidian malls coming in
one sold for 272 two sold for
272 and two more coming in at 240 going
to sell those off for 272 as well I
think we should just run with this I
don't really see any other items I have
near as good a margin and we've over one
wow we're up to like 300K profit that's
extremely good and uh 240 we're going to
go for that as well I don't know what
the limit is on this but well we'll do
two can't really imagine getting more
than that at a time and hopefully the
limit isn't eight you know what just
another random item I thought of the
Warriors ring we're going to have a
quick look at that because it's very
cheap and is on along the lines of the
Archer ring I trade very quickly so if
we have a look let's get it open here uh
looks like it has a 3 or 4K margin not
huge by any means but I mean we know how
much else is going on if we can flip
eight of these in under 10 minutes
easily assuming we get the right price
let's see here yeah like look 31 of
those that's a ton uh we'll try buying
them for let's see Warriors ring and
we'll try buying for
106 900 and we're going to go for as
much as we can afford which is five at
the time and we have another obsidian
Mall coming in for 272 going to pop
another one in quick all right we're
back again and we have another obsidian
Mall coming in for 272 that is a great
margin still Warriors ring we did get
one for 107 and we're going to try
selling it for I 109 500 or something
and pretty small margin but uh kind of
ran out of items I do I didn't think I'd
burn through them this quickly that is
pretty
good and we'll do as much as we can
forward which is not that many at a
time what is that going to be
like
and yeah 17 seeds yeah all right so we
have another obsidian mod coming in for
240 once again we'll sell it for 272k
all right another obsidian Mall coming
in uh 272 happy with that actually
impressed by how long these RAR seeds
took to come through
3547 and we're going to selling for uh
what was it 31 383 we'll try
that 31
380 533 and we bought them for 519 I
mean it's pretty good actually for uh
the price anyway 15 more seeds we'll
give it a try and we hopefully can get
one more of these but we're running of
time only 8 minutes left not very much
time left okay so the RAR seeds have
sold off uh 31 380 not bad and looks
like a couple more are coming through
now we are down to six minutes left I
think we're just going to pull this out
and just focus on selling the items and
these Warriors rings I guess we'll drop
down a little bit more
108 ow [__] I don't really care about
these 107 999 I think we're only getting
like a 1K margin now not that great uh
but still extremely happy with how this
hour is gone and we'll just wrap it up
and sell everything off all right guys
that's it surprisingly the Renard seeds
were the last to sell who thought but
anyway let's collect and stop the timer
and see how much we actually made from 1
hour of flipping from a 1 mil start take
the rars out that brings us up to 100
1.2 mil and take these out bring this up
to
1475 that is crazy I've never gotten a
return on a starting cash attack like
that before that's nearly 50% of our
initial cash T we earned just in 1 hour
just goes to show that um you can flip
from a 1 mil start you just have to find
some more unique items now what I was
mostly successful with were cheaper
items that weren't high volume per se
but they were rares uh kind of the same
way I do it when I start with 100 Mil
just scale down obviously um going over
what items work the best the Unholy
blessing was exceptionally good 20K on
that uh the fra brard was pretty weak
the Brian saber didn't end end up
working zamra plate body is really good
and um really honestly what how I found
all these items was just through G
tracker using their filters on high
volume items or high margin items oh my
God go away and uh that's pretty much
how I found all these items look most of
the ones I've tried were on the top here
but if you don't have this you can
easily go and look up these items for
yourselves and uh just explore look at
the wiki and clearly it is possible to
flip from one we start anyway I hope you
guys enjoyed if you did please leave a
suggestion for another 1hour flipping
challenge I can do I'm 25 or 26 episodes
in so I've gone through a lot of the
ideas so appreciate you watching and I
will see you guys in the next video
[Music]